FBI.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE HAS BEEN GOING
THROUGH THE FINDINGS AND
JOINS US NOW.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THANK YOU, BRET.
THE SPECIAL ATTORNEY GENERAL
ANDREW MCCABE LIED FOUR
TIMES.
THREE TIMES UNDER OATH ABOUT
HIS ROLE CONFIRMING THE
EXISTENCE OF THE FBI'S
CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION JUST TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
ACCORDING TO HOROWITZ,
MCCABE WAS ANGLINGED BY A
"WALL STREET JOURNAL"
ARTICLE SUGGESTING HE HAD A
CONFLICT BECAUSE HIS WIFE
RECEIVED MORE THAN $600,000
FROM DEMOCRATS FOR 2015
VIRGINIA STATE SENATE RACE
THAT SHE LOST.
MCCABE AUTHORIZED FBI LAWYER
LISA PAGE AND THE FBI'S
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CHIEF MICHAEL
CORNYN TO DISCUSS ISSUES
RELATE DOLLARS TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION.
INCLUDING A DRAMATIC PHONE
CALL BETWEEN MCCABE AND
SENIOR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL.
SOME OF THE KEY EVIDENCE IN
THIS CASE COMES BETWEEN TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN MCCABE AND.
INFORMATION TO RELEASE IF
CERTAIN CONDITIONS WERE MET.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND
MCCABE ACT FODZ PERSON.
CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION THROUGH
ANONYMOUSLY SOURCED QUOTE
RECALLING THE PHONE CALL
WITH SENIOR DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL IN A MANNER TO
ADVANCE HIS PERSONAL
INTEREST AT THE EXPENSE OF
DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP WAS
CLEARLY NOT WITHIN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST EXCEPTION.
THIS AFTERNOON, PRESIDENT
TRUMP TWEETED MCCABE LIED
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THAT MCCABE WAS CONTROLLED
BY HIS BOSS DIRECTOR COMEY
AND HE CLAIMED THERE WAS NO
DAYLIGHT BETWEEN THE TWO
MEN.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY PUT IT THIS WAY:
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN A FULL
REPORT, BUT SOUNDS LIKE TWO
PEAS IN A POD WITH MCCABE
AND COMEY.
MCCABE WAS FIRED IN DISGRACE
FOR MISCONDUCT AND LYING
ABOUT IT.
>> IN A STATEMENT MCCABE'S
ATTORNEY SAID THE
TERMINATION OF MR. MCCABE
WAS COMPLETELY UNJUSTIFIED.
AND THE RUSH TO FIRE HIM AT
THE GOADING OF THE PRESIDENT
WAS UNWORTHY OF THE GREAT
TRADITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
KEY FOOTNOTE IN THE REPORT
ARGUED MCCABE'S ACCOUNT WAS
MORE CREDIBLE THAN COMEY'S
BECAUSE OLD BOSS WANTED TO
DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM LEAKS.